もっぷりんだよねー
夢レバーソレル
明るくするよがんばってね少し遅れたんですけども
よこの日がきましたねはいなんやかんや
肇社長ターン
3色ちゃっちゃうってないんだいや初めて2ちゃんねる
北そしてば酒に手伝ってもらってここまで来たんですけどもう
今回新たに
あなたにいってわけでもないんか改めてですねはい
温めて新しいメンバーを紹介したいと思いますどうぞ
[音楽]
4日
ビッ
すればでこれは別のバックショットのがいいなどれだけば帰ってどうぞ
ココはいって何あったので行った活動玲奈
多分た鳥瞰していうことじゃね ig けど改めます客ビッグ社長えええ
本当おかえりなさいだよね皆さんありがたい台湾旅行なると思ってなかったよ
いや僕も持ってなかったうーんちょっと期待しだ
いろいろな言葉私も考えた末に怒られると思って今回戻ってきていたダイアーデー今後
はねうえぜひあっをよろしくお願い致しますというお話でございま
はあそうですねなんで5をチャンネル名は今始めシャツになってるんですけども
ひょっとしたら形的には僕が youtube はじめた頃のスタートですねはじめ
頑張るというお恥ずかしいのでやっていた時期もありました
まあそれに戻ったと言っても過言じゃないと思っている私はわかんね僕もひょっとし
たら一人で撮りたい時の動画までかもしれないし
なぜ撮りたい動画もあると
思うので上陸しちゃって
[音楽]
ん
はて人に
楽しくやっていければいいと思っております始めたねなんか楽しみだねあの参加この3
人が集まって出来るって言うか
また目ここ辺の事は結構皆さん知ってると思うんですけども
百味のことをヒットしたら知らない人も多いかも知れぬんぞ続くぜご紹介ほとんど
明るくで行っカルキでいいとはじめと大学の時にあってこれを一番はじめに
2最初にはじめカンパニーが始まった時にいたうちの一人です
昔の動画で多分再生があったところで言うと自分が大学卒業する時の動画とかが変わっ
たからと思います卒業式だねうんです
これはガチラキの動画じゃ懐かしいなぁ+4
そんな尽くす後雅紀をはめたと思うとかよゴリラーのリアー
とか人を信じられないけどそう
なのに就職したんですね就職して2年間働いててその間わー
private dance 向こうに遊びに行きたいだするけど喫茶で働いている
からね
でまだもうちょっともうちょっとだなもうちょっとやっぱり色々高コスト化しなきゃ
いいこともいろいろあるのですぐに手が来るわけでもないのでパッドにまた動画に入っ
てくると思いますはいというわけで退く意向なんか特別 bad girl わけでも
ないんですけども
の色々と今までにないような動画も作っていければいいなと思っております
おめで課題中に
ね正しいて自分にホルモンニートだからねじゃなきゃいけなかっただけでも頑張って
いきましょう
yeah
[拍手]
ええええええ